[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue
l'émission long débat de l'actualité
l'actualité qui passe aujourd'hui par
l'afrique et le burkina faso où emmanuel
macron a prononcé un long discours et
n'a pas hésité à répondre aux questions
qui fâchent on verra tout cela dans un
instant nous parlerons aussi du code du
travail
ça y est c'est aujourd'hui le vote de la
ratification des ordonnances il sera
aussi question du glyphosate herbicide
désormais bien connu son utilisation
prolongée de cinq ans par l'union
européenne soulève bien des controverses
et enfin encore un peu de politique bien
française avec cet épilogue pour le
feuilleton thierry solère qui a
finalement décidé de renoncer à son
poste de questeur à l'assemblée
bonjour thomas legrand bonjour vous êtes
éditorialiste politique à france inter
vous observer de près les soubresauts de
la vie politique et vous avez publié
chronique de l'imprévu c'est paru chez
stock et c'était sur notamment la
campagne présidentielle et c'est surtout
l'année et le feu 2016-2017 exactement
bienvenue dans point de vue bonjour
daniel bilalian bonjour vous avez dirigé
des sports à france télévisions vous
avez été présentateur du journal
télévisé et vous parlait volontiers et
très bien de sport de politiques et des
sujets de société
merci d'être avec nous
bonjour cécile crouzet l'on vous êtes
chef adjoint du service macroéconomie
france vous aimez les chaque jour les
chevaux des politiques et des réformes
économiques et vous allez nous parler de
tout cela
bonjour alexandre ii vecchio journaliste
au service débat opinion du figaro vous
vous occupez plus particulièrement de
figaro vox en 2016 vous avez publié les
nouveaux enfants du secte du siècle
c'était aux éditions du cerf alors cette
visite d' emmanuel macron en afrique une
visite mouvementée qu'a commencé le
président au burkina faso après une
attaque à la grenade un jet de pierre
sur un bus de la délégation le président
a prononcé un long discours dans le
chaudron de l'université de ouagadougou
chaudron au sens propre comme figuré
parce que la clim était en panne et
l'ambiance assez survolté 1h45 de
discours on va en a sélectionné un
extrait qu'on va regarder puis en retard
je ne vais pas venir ici vous dire que
nous allons faire un grand discours pour
une bulle une nouvelle base de la
relation entre la france et l'afrique
je ne suis pas venu ici vous dire quelle
est la politique africaine de la france
comme d'aucuns le prétendent parce qu'il
n'y a plus de politique africaine de la
france
thomas legrand je commence par vous je
ferai un tour de table vous l'avez
commence trouver comment ce discours
d'un mot j'ai trouvé plutôt bon et
efficace
assez assez malin il n'y a plus de
politique africaine de la france c'est
ce que les africains les jeunes
étudiants africains vont évidemment qui
a une politique africaine de la france
et heureusement parce que parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de questions à se poser sur nos
sources d'énergie sur l'immigration et
puis sur ce pays sur ce continent qu'on
dit le continent de demain de promesses
de croissance
heureusement qu'on a une politique
africaine à la pensée et démagogie vous
avez trouvé daniel bilalian face à ces
étudiants à propos de la politique
africaine de la france il faisait
allusion à la francafrique de faux car
depuis l'éternité
donc voilà donc effectivement c'est
assez malin il n'a pas fait l'erreur
qu'il avait fait en algérie il a dit il
a parlé des crimes de la colonisation
mais il a dit le passé est passé
ça va pas il a eu le courage de parler
de l'esclavagé en afrique qui était une
affaire africaine on va en parler et
dont je pense qu'il a été il a été assez
malin mais bon malin est une chose mais
l'efficacité sur le continent africain
c'est une autre affaire heureusement et
quelle politique africaine de la france
a honte pour ces questions terroristes
extérieurs qui sont pas réglés et aux
questions économiques aussi vaut mieux
parce que il ya des pays qui ont une
bonne crème politique africaine c'est la
chine ou l'inde
ils ont une bonne politique africaine
nous vaut mieux en avoir une chance aux
politiques économiques
en tout cas c'est sûr ça alexandre
vecchio vous reprenez le qualificatif de
courageux de dire qu'il avait plus fun
thomas legrand daniel bilalian dit il a
eu le courage quand même de répondre à
d'évoquer certaines questions
oui je pense que il a il a eu à coeur de
sortir un peu du paternaliste et du
paternalisme et de mettre les africains
finalement face à leur responsabilité de
leur dire finalement vous êtes maître de
votre destin pas ça me rappelle assez le
discours de nicolas sarkozy
simplement puisque c'est emmanuel macron
ça ne suscite aucun tollé mais dans le
fond le messager est un peu le même
sarkozy qui a eu cette phrase d'accord
qu'on rentrait dans l'histoire stade
discours d'henri guaino qui peut être
difficilement taxer de raciste plutôt
humaniste mais qui invitait justement ça
les africains à se prendre en main donc
c'était c'était une phrase un peu
maladroite mais on verra peut-être après
il eu des échanges assez musclé avec
macro et je note que ça suscite pas de
doute aux les particules et elle est
comme elle est là malgré ses causes et
les non initiés
c'est quand même déjà passé comme très
très méprisant enfin je pense que c'est
quand même une contre vérité historique
aussi enfin jeudi qu'il n'avait pas
écrit en fait si on regarde
si on regarde tous les grands discours
africain le discours en 1944 à
brazzaville du général de gaulle c'était
aussi prenez vous en main vous allez
vous prendre en main c'était ça
prévoyait la décolonisation il ya tous
les présidents qui après ont pratiqué la
françafrique pour sinon on peut la
critiquer d'ailleurs mais qu'ils l'ont
fait ont toujours dit ça parce que c'est
ce qu'on dit à un pays quand on est la
france et que et qu'on pense que les
peuples sont libres jusqu'à en 1989 je
crois à la baule françois mitterrand qui
disait maintenant les aides à l'afrique
seront conditionnés à la démocratisation
ce qui peut être considéré aussi comme
une forme de néo colonialiste bien
pensants ci ont beau si on peut dire lui
au moins il dit
prenez vous en main et les cette façon
de d'insister face aux étudiants puisque
encore une fois il y avait quand même
800 étudiants face à lui n'ayez pas
cette vision post coloniale les
renvoyant eux mêmes à leur propre zone
il ya quand même aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'africains se présente encore des comme
des victimes de la colonisation
si je ne me trompe pas il ya un demi
siècle que ces pays sont libérés et
indépendant et c'est vrai que l'afrique
a du mal à avoir des pays la gouverner
normalement démocratiquement c'est la
majorité sont des dictateurs la
corruption y est très importante
on dit toujours la corruption c'est de
la faute des grandes firmes qui viennent
s'installer mais personne n'a jamais
empêché un chef d'état africain d'être
honnête je sache on a maintenu on a
maintenu des chefs d'état africains pour
de bonnes ou mauvaises raisons de bonnes
parce qu'on voulait la stabilité et ça
c'était bon pour tout le monde de
mauvaises parce qu'on voulait surtout
assuré s'assurer les ressources en
pétrole en gaz et donc il ya eu la
colonisation il ya eu la décolonisation
il ya une sorte de néo colonialisme et
tout ça disparaît un peu et finalement
je trouve que quand emmanuel macron dit
prenez vous en main et on voudrait il ya
plus de politique de la france on vous
dira plus qu'il faut faire c'est à la
fois tout à fait vrai mais en même temps
il leur dit arrêtez de faire neuf
enfants
et puis donc c'est quand même quand même
des
si certains pensent qu'elle est non
changement de génération ceux des pays
très jeune donc les aider décolonisation
seuil à 50 ans mais 90% de la population
de ces pays là n'ont jamais connu la
colonisation lui-même du lauréat
changement génération y a changé une
fédération
d'ailleurs lui-même s'est présenté comme
quelqu'un de la génération mandela est
pas de mal
il ne nie pas les crimes mais il dit
sortie résidus 2 après cet hiver après
c'est un peu condescendant de dire à
quelqu'un prenez vous en main mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on parle à un ado ça
comme une influence par la politique
africaine munich aurait il faut éduquer
les jeunes il ordonne quelle année là
c'était plutôt parce que c'était pas à
ouagadougou c'était pendant le g20 en
juillet dernier où il avait parlé de
démographie en afrique on écoute et on
en reparle
quels sont les problèmes en afrique les
états faillis les transitions
démocratiques complexe la transition
démographique qui est gelée rappelé ce
matin l'un des défis essentiels de
l'afrique dans des pays ont encore
aujourd'hui sept à huit enfants par
femme vous pouvez décider d'y dépenser
des milliards d'euros vous ne se
stabiliserait rien il a redit
aujourd'hui la x c'est une vérité est ce
que c'est une vérité bonne à dire est ce
que ça fait un peu donneur de leçons
c'est une vérité soit hier pour
tradiction à dire effectivement je ne
suis pas là pour dégager des leçons mais
en même temps de vivre cette tradition
mais en même temps on a un problème de
deux d'immigration à gérer et puis donc
il ya une contradiction mais pourquoi ne
pas dire ça c'était aussi une vérité
c'est la politique africaine on y
revient toujours
c'est toujours finalement on ne peut pas
s'en défaire donc dire qu'il ya pas de
politique de l'afrique haine de la
france c'est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
encore une fois l'immigration était un
sujet qui n'a pas été abordée clairement
la pâte dit la france va limiter la
france va faire ceci cela il moi je n'ai
pas entendu de l'impôt même il a dit il
ya 10 pour traiter la racine
effectivement moins d'enfants et puis là
elle est
favoriser la croissance en afrique c'est
quand même maintenir les populations là
bas je crois que c'était lié
il ya un sujet que vous connaissez bien
alexandre que le président aussi abordé
c'est celui notamment de l'histoire d'
esclavagisme en libye où il a eu le
courage on peut le dire de répondre à un
étudiant qu'il met un peu en cause en
disant mais finalement voulait en libye
qu'est-ce qui les passeurs et tout ça ce
sont des africains cd voilà c'est une
forme de cétacés quand même alors que la
france a quand même une part de
responsabilité en libye même si la
traque africaine existe depuis longtemps
que bien avant les événements en libye
mais je pense que déstabiliser la libye
et macron il est pour rien a été nous
vos serrures de nicolas sarkozy donc la
question n'était pas totalement
illégitime il a quand même effectivement
le courage ne pas être dans un discours
victimaire je crois que le discours
victimaire aujourd'hui et la pire des
choses pour la pour l'afrique puisque
seuls les incite à ne pas prendre en
main leurs problèmes et à rester dedans
et en plus ça nourrit une forme de
ressentiment à l'égard de l'occident qui
ne qui ne mènent à rien donc je pense
que oui effectivement il a été plutôt
courageux de dire ça c'était une forme
d'honnêteté intellectuelle et je crois
de toute manière que c'est finalement
respecter son interlocuteur que de dire
certaines vérités
vous les avez senti vous connaissez
les étudiants et l'auditoire assez
déstabilisé par cette ce franc-parler où
je pense qu'ils s'y attendait c'est
toujours d'être point pour un président
avec son autorité d'arrivée devant une
assemblée d'étudiants c'est toujours
assez dangereux et en même temps et
d'étudiants africains dont qui vous
attend vraiment avec avec avec une sorte
d'avidité c'est à la fois dangereux et
on sait qui maniait le maquereau dans ce
milieu là dans dans un marigot comme ça
se débrouillant c'est trop bien mais
quand on nous a dit l'elysée n'avait pas
dicter les questions de savoir c'est
vrai peut-être je pense je pense pas
qu'ils aient peur de certaines questions
enfin je vois je vois partout il les a
limités en nombre mais je vois pas de
quelle question il pourrait avoir peur
donc on peut toujours imaginer président
être plus facile pour lui des étudiants
que les pontes de huy du régime qui a
sorti lorrain porte forcément un tabac
ou alors de ce fait des spécialistes
très pointus les étudiants pour ceux
toujours un peu plus le foutoir c'est
finalement c'est contrairement à ce
qu'on peut croire c'est sûrement plus
facile pour un homme comme et maquereau
qui est assez naturel devant les foules
cc coisel la délégation il ya notamment
on l'a créée dans le figaro pas mal de
dirigeants de start up qui accompagne
emmanuel moi c'est nouveau c'est peut
porter ses fruits
ça peut porter son entrée il ya tout un
mouvement là dessus dans chaque
délégation du medef ya des startups qui
partent sur l'afrique qui ça c'est
rigolo on compte du talent et une au
maroc rencontre des jeunes très très
entreprenante qui aime bien ce côté
africain il ya encore peu de formalisme
pour faire des affaires et c'est qu'ils
aiment bien ça il ya beaucoup
d'innovations aussi en afrique notamment
tout autour de la téléphonie mobile du
solaire etc
mais des moyens de paiement énormément
de gens payent par téléphone beaucoup
plus qu'en france il ya des tas de
services nouveaux comme ça qui se met en
place il ya un saut technologique qui se
fait donc c'est intéressant aussi pour
des entreprises y aller et de voir un
peu ce qui se passe là bas et c'est pas
complètement talent chez ce que vous
disiez au début la chine de l'inde qui
investissent en masse
oui ils investissent beaucoup dans les
infrastructures et notamment tout ce qui
est ma terre première oui ça
contrebalançant parti après c'est pas
c'est pas très simple et contrats
d'énergie renouvelable on part de zéro
et on se crée beaucoup de choses oui
mais là aussi c'est habile le côté pour
une fois on n'y va pas avec les grands
patrons de grandes entreprises
françaises qui ont déjà des décennies
d'après-guerre ya bien installée dans
l'avion on sait que on sait qu'il ya des
choses pas très nettes aussi autour des
grandes entreprises françaises qui ont
besoin de sécuriser leurs
approvisionnements
mais on sait aussi que c'est enfin je
peux pas vous le savez mieux que moi
certainement que on nous dit depuis
quelques années que c'est le prochain
continent de la croissance voilà deux
donc c'est là qu'il faut aller à ça
c'est sûr il n'est pas sûr change un peu
un peu très à gauche en disant je suis
pas venu avec les grands patrons
terex affriolants delà les secours du
bourget président on à eric qui pose une
bonne question qui nous dit pourquoi est
il allé dans ces pays là le choix de ses
trois filles unités pendant ces pays là
on a pris à ces pays-là en appoint qui
voulait déjà faire un tour dans un pays
anglophone williams
donc c'est pour montrer que il vient y
vient pas en chef de la françafrique
dans son pré carré il va la croissance
c'est plutôt les pays anglophones
d'ailleurs donc bien joaquin arias il ya
surtout fins est en première ligne dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme
et puis le processus démocratique et
qu'il tombe bien car le bringuebal petit
hommage à thomas sankara qui est très
habile au canada et avec la promesse de
sa et sas est classifié secret bien de
déclassifier les documents parce que
tout ce qui peut éteindre les théories
du complot qui en afrique comme ailleurs
mais beaucoup en a fait en afrique
nouri justement l'esprit victimaire qui
est assez délétère ça peut être bien je
reviens une seconde sur le c'est vrai
qu'il a dit les crimes commis par la
colonisation et non pas les crimes
contre l'humanité façon qu'il avait de
se qualifier 4 étoiles avait fait une
erreur la dernière fois autant il est
indéniable et crime ça vous convient
alexandre oui moi je pense qu'il ya eu
des crimes pendant la colonisation il a
dit aussi que c'était du passé et qu'il
faut il ne fallait pas rester enfermé
dans le passé donc autant la première
expression m'avait choqué autant autant
là je crois que c'est indéniable sur le
plan sur le plan historique mois là où
je pense qu'il ya un paradoxe malgré
tout même si d'un côté j'aime bien la
peine à se prendre en main c'est que les
difficultés sont aujourd'hui tels que je
me demande s'il ne va pas y avoir une
forme de dell de développement qui
pourrait presque s'apparenter à du néo
colonial et je me demande c'est face au
phénomène effectivement démographique
qu'on nous annonce le rôle des pays
européens n'est pas de s'investir
beaucoup plus largement qu'il est le
fond donc ça c'est c'est un paradoxe
intéressant il a quand même vie alors
que les sommes sont assez modestes il a
quand même dit que l'aide aux bourses
pour les étudiants serait ciblé
directement sur les jeunes filles
ce qui paraît il a fait ça j'ai pas vu
oui justement puisse bosser et qu'elles
décident s'ils veulent avoir deux trois
enfants qu'elles sont pas obligés d'en
avoir huit à partir de 14 ans donc il y
a quand même
après je pense que sur dans ces domaines
là peut être allé un peu en afrique vam
les choses qui changent dans les grandes
métropoles africaines au niger c'est
vrai qu'à 7 enfants par femme et ses
satisfactions terim vous allez dans les
grandes métropoles jours à abidjan tout
ça même au togo à lomé tout ça les gens
ont déjà beaucoup beaucoup moins
d'enfants il ya déjà une volonté des
gens qui sont dans la classe moyenne de
réduire donc cesser une transition un
qui est lente mais c'est une tradition
déjà en cours ces voix là oui moi je
crois quand même que face aux défis
migratoires il faudra plus volant doit
être en passer par un plan marshall pour
l'afrique et dans le plan marshall et à
l'administration américaine en europe
voilà ça va assez loin en lui demandant
là on a un commentaire de loki qui
estime que les responsabilités de la
france en afrique sont innombrables
aujourd'hui l'heure est au bilan à la
prospective et surtout à l'innovation
diplomatiques alors est ce que c'est un
plan marshall est ce que c'est
on verra ça on va parler maintenant un
petit peu des ordonnances sur la loi
travail alors est ce la victoire finale
en tout cas c'est la dernière victoire
pour le nouveau code du travail
la ratification des ordonnances et
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée est
l'aboutissement de la première grande
réforme sociale du quinquennat est ce le
symbole de l'échec des oppositions
qu'elle soit syndicales ou de la france
insoumise un échec c'est évidemment pas
l'avis ni de jean claude mailly le
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
need alexis corbière député de la france
a soumises qui étaient tous les deux des
invités de rtl et europe 1 ce matin on
les écoutait victoire je ne dirais pas
ça puisque le dossier tel qu'il sort
n'est pas celui qui était envisagé au
début de l'art maintenant il a réussi à
faire une réforme du code du travail
comme il l'avait annoncé maintenant oui
la fusion des institutions
représentatives du personnel ça va poser
de nombreux de nombreux problèmes c'est
un échec pour je prends de 18 millions
de salariés 1
franchement le jeu ne se sont pas
mobilisés pour
oui mais qui n'ont désormais chez est un
grand enthousiasme non plus chaque fois
que les études d'opinion été fait je
crois qu'il ya dans cette histoire en
mauvais coups qui est portée contre
peuple français ils sont mauvais perdant
c'est probable oui oui oui c'est comme
une victoire d'emmanuel mâcon il a passé
il a passé sa réforme qui avait suscité
énormément de remous sur françois
hollande
une version plus allégée avait pu
susciter énormément de romont sous
françois hollande a il a passé sans trop
de remous c'est incontestablement une
réussite il a pour lui aussi c'est vrai
que françois hollande a préparé le
terrain de d'habitude accoutumé à ces
idées là et puis surtout en fait toutes
les manifestations de 2016 ont usé les
centrales syndicales les militants et
c'est donc lui est arrivé avec vingt qui
voit là des militants qui avaient plus
de courage rebondir sur des mois de
manifestations pour pas grand chose donc
ça aussi hollande l'a préparé le terrain
en fait il a été aidé par marc martinez
la cgt quand même parce que le côté
cégétiste des années 50 non à tout et
les réformes sont bonnes pour tous les
autres ça a facilité les choses parce
que l'opinion publique elle se rend
compte que un monsieur comme ça il
entraîne le jusqu'à huit semaines
affectent ils ne payent pas moi je pense
que les rêves dans ce qui est le plus
important dans les réformes c'est le
nouveau barème pour les licenciements
abusifs ça c'est une bonne chose
un barème fixé et puis la deuxième chose
c'est le regroupement l'adie de la
disparition des seiches c'était j'ai été
à un moment de ma vie
directeur dans une entreprise et les
ruelles c'était c'est un exercice de zen
pour un yoga for télévision gibrat chefs
d'entreprise à parce qu'il ya des
moments non je pense qu'une seule une
seule entité est largement suffisante
parce que sinon on est on est tous les
deux jours on a annoncé une action en
justice un sur la fusion mais la chose
qui n'a pas été au bout de ce qu'ils
voulaient faire un moment donné quand
même c'est la discussion par entreprise
et par branche la branche
c'est à dire les syndicats restent
importants et beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise je voulais qu'on discute
entreprise par entreprise et par branche
par branche et là les syndicats ont
gagné ils ont conservé la majorité dans
ce domaine là thomas legrand c'est vrai
qu'on disait après l'élection ça va être
quand c'est annoncé cette réforme ça va
être un obtient quelque chose de majeur
une montagne à franchir et à un des
commentaires de se demander si ça la
période chômée
mais c'était assez évident que enfin la
mère des réformes oui bien sûr mais la
différence entre moi je pense pas que
les salariés et les syndicats étaient
fatigués après une connerie c'est
simplement que quand françois hollande
propose quelque chose même de ne pas
alléger et qu'il le fait en fin de
mandat alors qu'il n'avait pas promis
pendant sa campagne il y à il ya quelque
chose de démocratiquement gênant là il
dit ce qui fait ival il dit exactement
il le fait
les gens fort de la légitimité toute
fraîche qu'ils ont même négative
c'est-à-dire que l'on dit on dit il a eu
que 20 24% au premier tour et puis ils
n'ont pas voté pour ça il monte contre
marine le pen menton va en tout cas ils
ont voté malgré ça et même si une
majorité de français aiment bien le
changement mais n'aime pas changer au
moment où il applique la politique il
avait annoncé pour laquelle il a été élu
les français même râleurs dix bons font
un pari c'est là que c'est assez fragile
parce qu'ils disent bon bah on a essayé
plein de trucs ça lui le propose il est
jeune il est il allé les malades du
pouvoir ce qui embête les français
depuis des années c'est l'impuissance
publique aussi ses 2 d'arriver au
pouvoir en disant je vais faire si
pineuilh jamais rien faire donc là on
lui donne les clefs
même si on n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord il faut pas lui envoyer enlever
les moyens donc s'il s'y grogne du royal
à voir
dans quelques mois je pense si ça marche
pas mal sûr là c'est la bonne méthode
finalement sur la sur le fond sur le
fond je pense que les français sont
résignés et 50 % n'ont pas voté aux
législatives c'est sa première réforme
il était évident que qu'elle allait
passer face à des syndicats également
décrédibiliser et affaibli après moi ce
que je pense de lui de la réforme sur le
fond c'est que c'est une réforme qui va
pas faire de mal qui va simplifier les
choses à certains pas trop mais qui est
d'un conformisme économique total c'est
la réforme dans la continuité des
réformes qu'on affronte qu'on a connus
ces dernières années et ça ne ne créera
pas un emploi jeu j'en prends le le pari
si moi je crois que oui on arrête son
patrimoine à des élites effectivement
qui depuis des années ne jure que par
plus de flexibilité qui voit simplement
le tertiaire ou pour ront les start up
au moi je le dis je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent qu'un pays sans industrie
est un pays qui nord et il n'y a rien
pour l'instant là-dessus
l'investissement productif et quelque
chose de totalement absente son
raisonnement où on a l'impression qu'ils
pensent que les usines sont des
vieilleries et vous qu'on va avoir pour
l'instant le moi je trouve que c'est
assez
entre le fait de s'occuper avec je vois
pas du tout la compatibilité on peut
faire la paix qui avait incompatibilité
g10 qui existeraient 10 fait que je dis
bon on va voir pour l'instant c'est le
flou mais je pense que son penchant
naturel mais pas forcément à aller vers
des investissements productifs
après si je me trompe alors j'attends de
creuser encore incompatibles c'est sur
le rhône a souvent dit on l'emploie
mais il était dit que ça créerait des
emplois comme ça massivement et xsara et
surtout pas la plus grande réforme
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale a pas
assez investi dans l'industrie on espère
le fait de détaxer les gars alors c'est
peut-être que c'est pas ce qu'il va se
passer
vous avez peut-être raison mais en tout
cas l'intention que les capitaux plutôt
que d'être taxés aïe
c'est une autre réforme je vais en
estrie je pense pas qu'on puisse c'est
un procès d'intention vous fait vous
vous avez le droit de dire ça marchera
pas celle ci mais enfin il le veut si on
en parle tout le temps mais il ya en
france et très peu de en fait preuve je
pense qu'en france c'est qu'on parle là
flexible alors dire on va faire des
réformes libérales on ne les fait pas ou
a minima et on a un pays où il ya 57 %
du pib qui part en dépenses publiques où
il ya peu de flexibilité en comparaison
des autres pays
donc en fait on parle de ça donc la
pression des gens ont l'impression qu'on
mène cette politique mais on ne l'a même
pas dans les fêtes on perd sur deux les
choses et de plans - gers la critique et
en à zéro efficacité
c'est ce que j'allais dire généraliser
le élément essentiel d'une politique
industrielle plus plus dynamique ça il
n'en est pas question une seule seconde
dans les lois et c'est pas en réformant
les licenciements abusifs et en
supprimant le chsct que on va engager
des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes ce sont des sons des
changements administratifs ne sont pas
déjà les dires des changements
industriels à ce matin il suffisait
d'écouter les radios ou de lire les
journaux la société générale qui
supprime des agences les galeries
lafayette qui se réduisent ils français
peuvent se dire du bien du je suis
amoureux dit pas vraiment ses effets
alors non enfin allez les filles on est
comme sur des c'est plus compliqué que
ça tombe bien se focaliser sur quelques
actions immédiates mais on est on est un
rythme de 300 mille créations d'emplois
en france à peu près depuis un an donc
on n'est pas du tout dans des
destructions d'emplois contrairement à
ce qu'on a connu dans les années 2012
2013 1014 qui était noir après sur les
chiffres du chômage c'est la confusion
parce que ça exactement pire plus comme
françois hollande a fait son plan
formation des gens sont partis en fin
d'instruction là ils reviennent dans les
chiffres du chômage tout assez
embrouillée en tout cas c'est que ça se
réduit beaucoup moins vite que parfois
le rythme ne créant sûrement pas mais
oui on est on est pas en france pour
l'instant dans un bain dans un dans une
récession n'emploie pas du tout en ce
moment ils profitent même plutôt
emmanuel macron d'une bonne conjoncture
quoi il a plutôt de la chance de sauter
ce côté là donc oui il ya des réductions
dans pomme il ya des mini partout qui se
crée donc on parle pas donc voilà si un
billet énorme là dessus alors agent qui
s'interroge kim aris une loi de travail
une loi travail libéral la victoire du
libéralisme ou une réforme est plutôt
une réformette ceni le hall la grande
purge libérale qu'on pouvait craindre ni
une réformes structurelles d'ampleur en
tout cas c'est pas la plus grande
réforme depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale comme il l'a annoncé ça c'est
de la propagande
voilà moi je maintiens que on a un
chômage structurel à 10% et que ce type
de réforme ne changera pas grand chose
alors on va passer à un autre thème si
vous devez bien celui du glyphosate le
glyphosate
la france peut-elle faire cavalier seul
on s'y perd un peu et est reparti pour
cinq ans où finit dans trois ans qui a
raison bruxelles qui autorise donc le
renouvellement de l'herbicide pour cinq
ans paris emmanuel macron qui décrète la
fin du glyphosate dans trois ans est-ce
pour la france l'occasion de repenser
tout son modèle d'agriculture c'est en
tout cas l'avis de yannick jadot et
yannick jadot le député europe ecologie
les verts qui était ce matin l'invité de
france inter à partir du moment où on
interdira le glyphosate
je peux vous garantir qu'on continuera à
cultiver des céréales dans la boue ce
simplement peut-être avec les 10
milliards d'euros d'argent public qui
arrive sur l'agriculture
chaque année eh ben plutôt que d'avoir
un seul agriculteur sur 200 hectares et
ben y en aura deux et c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour l'emploi dans l'habitude
avant de lancer le débat on va regarder
également le
numéro deux de la fnsea qui vous vous en
doutez n'est pas tout à fait du même
avis que yannick jadot on écoute
éric thirouin il était sur europe 1 ce
matin la france décide elle de revenir -
j'ose le dire au nationalisme avec des
mesures franco française c'est à dire
mais c'est à dire que l'europe ça fait
deux ans qui a une bagarre pour avoir
une position ferme et sur cette
colocation ou pas du glyphosate
il ya une majorité pour le faire et la
france tout seul dit ah bah nan là -
finalement deux heures après je décide
de faire une mesure franco française et
donc les agriculteurs là-dedans qu'est
ce qu'il devienne monsieur le président
de la république est ce qu'ils
deviennent alors que dire les
agriculteurs mais d'abord une question
aussi alexander et qui ont un thème qui
doit vous plaire
emmanuel macron quand ça l'arrangé les
dans l'europe quand ça les arrange plus
il s'en affranchit oui mais c'est plutôt
pour pour me plaire c'est vrai que ces
grands discours sur l'europe fédérale me
font plutôt plutôt peur mais là je
trouve que je n'ai pas d'avis sur le
fond sur le glyphosate parce que c'est
vite il pas utile mais par contre je
trouve qu'un président français qui
décide souverainement c'est plutôt une
une bonne chose tout à l'heure en parler
d'industrie je peux parler de
protectionnisme et je trouve que vaut
effectivement on doit être maître de sa
de sa politique donc c'est plutôt pour
murray qui formeraient existe au
contraire et j'ai par exemple pas le
nommer on doit on doit réduire notre
déficit en dessous de 3%
on va pas condamner ceux qui le
réduisent simplement à 2%
voilà on fait on fait mieux de mon point
de vue on va plus vite que que l'europe
si emmanuel macron avait dit je veux pas
de jeu pas le renouveler pour cinq ans
mais pour sept ans là il aurait fait il
aurait fait pire mais c'est plutôt une
mesure ça j'ai quand même un petit peu
compliqué dans le message est peut-être
un peu compliqué surtout l'application
va être très compliqué parce qu'est ce
qu'on va interdire le blé qui aura été
cultivé avec un du désherbant glyphosate
de devenir en france est-ce qu'on va
trier les céréales dans les boîtes de
kellogg's pour savoir si faut pas dire
de barques et enfin bon c'est compliqué
mais le message qui est
arrêtons glyphosate et essayons d'avoir
une agriculture un peu plus raisonnée
moi je trouve qu'il est bien et je pense
que la france grande nation agricole a
raison elle est dans le sens de
l'histoire en faisant ça c'est peut-être
là
des citoyennes non ce qui me ce qui
m'intéresse dans cette affaire-là c'est
que emmanuel macron comptait beaucoup
s'appuyer sur anglet la merkel ça fait
déjà entre les difficultés qu'elle a
formé un gouvernement
le vote d'hier l'alliance le binôme
commence à être bien fonctionné en plus
les allemands aujourd'hui on dit que
madame merkel a engueulé sont mises de
l'agriculture en lisant on te l'avait
demandé alors je sais pas s'il ya le
téléphone c'est la dépêche james à l est
pas arrivé à temps dans une autre
formulation non parce qu'il faut pas non
plus oublier que les allemands ont une
très grande société qui s'appelle
bailleurs qui va être achetée sans
racheter monsanto
donc il ya des intérêts économiques dont
on nous parle pas aujourd'hui on nous
amuse avec il faut at 5 en trois ans
mais il ya des intérêts économiques et
mais c'est surtout que l'europe que vous
voulez diriger madame merkel et que
surtout macron voulait diriger avec
madame merkel en ce moment ça ça va de
la madeleine et il ya une question quand
même de la mise en oeuvre effectivement
de ces trois ans au lieu de cinq
parce que là effectivement comment on va
faire deux ans voilà on peut on peut
lâcher pour la cerise il on a mis en
place un système qui empêché d'apporter
des cerises qui avaient été traitées et
qu'un herbe un pesticide que nous on
n'avait pas eu eux nous on avait
interdit moi c'était la cerise quoi là
on est soluble et voilà exactement et
puissance apu très inquiet et puis c'est
une production massive ou avoir la foi
la france a on a parqué dans sa phrase
dans son tweet c'est il ya un peu sous
réserve de trouver une solution donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas mal
selena non mais c'est comme ça mais moi
c'est pas bien faire l'exact cédé que
des alternatives
4 voir le tweet est que des alternatives
rond et étroit et si on ne trouve pas
bon enfant comme les autres mais c'est
aussi pas mal de mettre des gants pour
la voiture de m ddd cap assez ambitieux
parce que il faut il faut bien se forcer
à trouver autre chose et forcer les
investisseurs à investir dans quelque
chose de l'alternatif alors jean
baptiste émergents qu'on accueille avec
grand plaisir
bonjour bonjour jean baptiste parce que
vous êtes
intéressé jean baptiste sur les réseaux
sociaux ou hashtag make or planète
oui effectivement dans son tweet qui
était quand même assez rapide emmanuel
macron a ajouté son hashtag make our
planet 8e gagne la punchline qu'il avait
trouvé en juin dernier en réponse à
donald trump donald trump avait refusé
que les états unis aux restes dans la
corde climatique de paris donc c'est ce
slogan avait apparemment été trouvé par
semaine et me lien qui est un de ses
conseillers les plus proches et une
vidéo puis un visuel spécifique avait
été publiée sur le compte twitter des
manuels macron l'elysée avait ensuite
lancé un site internet qui s'appelait
make our planet great games en appel à
des chercheurs du monde entier afin
qu'ils se recensent pour montrer qu'ils
étaient capables ou s'il avait envie de
venir en france
en tout cas pour travailler et cherchait
bon faut dire que cette hashtag n'a pas
été que utilisé par des chercheurs
benoît hamon l'a utilisé il n'y a pas
très longtemps où il expliquait que les
substances cancérigènes avait été exclu
du nouveau compte pénibilité il ya eu à
peu près 35 mille tweets avec le hashtag
mec avoir planning de gamme ce qui est
quand même pas mal
patrick pouyanné le pdg de total lui
était parlé des dividendes carbone donc
c'est ça va quand même assez large
beaucoup de personnes ont utilisé ce
hashtag s'appelle du news jacking c'est
à dire qu'on récupère un hashtag à tout
le monde prend la parole sur le sujet
oui j'ai trouvé encore plus incroyable
samuel le bihan l'acteur samuel le bihan
a croisé le ministre nicolas hulot dans
le train c'était une belle rencontre il
a aussi utilisé le hashtag make our
planet 8 e gueye donc un peu injuste a
que pour tout un tas valide
schwarzenegger au sénégal il avait pas
utiliser ces macron qu'il avait cité le
tweet de chasse à des guerres il va
réutiliser le m donc voilà le président
a bien tweeté à ressortir son hashtag de
résistance contre l'aube ce qui arrive
contre vie ce qui est un petit peu le
critique et cette fois-ci peut-être
qu'il va chercher des chercheurs
allemands parce que bon voilà les
chercheurs allemands ont peut-être aussi
envie de venir travailler en france et
vous avez même josé bové qu'il a soutenu
hier en anglais où il rappelle que la
lutte continue la lutte quand le lift
hosatte n'est pas terminée et en
attendant le site make our planet great
games le fameux site à récupérer 250
candidatures de chercheurs et les
résultera les résultats normalement
seront le 12 décembre pour fêter les
deux ans de la coop 21 une dizaine de
personnes sera sélectionné suspense
alors oui c'est vrai d'abord si samuel
le bihan la rencontre m et on l'a alors
comme allemand nicolas hulot l'a pas
entendu je pense que c'est apple qui
mixe de france oui je pense que si
emmanuel macron a tweeté ce n'est pas
son habitude dans l'avion en partant en
afrique trois ans pour les couples non
c'était surtout parce que il ya
peut-être une encore une menace de
démission et que mon avis on l'a entendu
via le tweet attendu alors si du
subliminal et nicolas hulot
non c'est pas écolo qui me l'a dit ce
matin à un tout autre sujet la politique
bien française à nouveau la situation
était devenue politiquement intenable
thierry solère député constructif passé
en marche a été obligé de lâcher son
poste de questeur à l'assemblée le
député des hauts-de-seine l'annoncé ce
matin cela devenait difficile de
s'accrocher à une fonction qui n'est pas
dépourvue davantage matériel c'est le
président de l'assemblée nationale
françois de rugy qui lui a donné le coup
de grâce si l'on peut dire
on écoute françois de rugy c'était sur
bfm tv l'intérêt de l'assemblée
nationale serait qu est que thierry
solère abandonne la questure pourquoi
pour la raison que vous avez rappelé
rapidement les questeurs ils sont trois
c'est une gestion collégiale de
l'assemblée nationale et pour qu'il y
ait une garantie de transparence dans
l'utilisation des du budget de
l'assemblée nationale il a toujours été
prévu que les questeurs n'appartiennent
pas au même groupe attendant le grand
site est devenu un peur franche c'est la
moindre des choses
s'ils veulent passer d'un ancien monde
un nouveau monde politique il faut au
moins qu'ils respectent ce qu'il y avait
de pas mal dans l'ancien monde c'est à
dire qu'à l'assemblée nationale qui a
déjà pas beaucoup de pouvoir
il ya trois questeurs dont ckoi les
questeurs c'est ce qui gère l'argent g20
nationale et qui organise la tour
nationale il faut que ça soit évidemment
de la majorité et de l'opposition il
faut et là à partir du moment déjà
questeur en tant que constructif
c'était limite il a voté la confiance il
a voté le budget dont il est dans la
majorité
là le troisième le questeur doit être
détenu par le principal parti
d'opposition groupe d'opposition je
pense à elle
j'imagine que c'est l air donc ça doit
être un heller forcément qui va avoir
mais est-ce que c'était forcément à
thierry solère de renoncer ou on aurait
pu alors autant marge aurait vu aurait
pu décider c'est bon ils auraient pu
décider
c'était un est troisième mais enfin bon
lui il arrive au dernier moment ça
paraît logique
déjà avant il aurait dû renoncer eric
ciotti pour le remplacer un pour le
succession après je sais pas ce n'est
pas un salaire non mais ce qui est ce
qui est extra dire si on parlait de la
nouveauté de la politique de macron mais
là je vois que sur l'assemblée nationale
ça continue bien comme avant
au lieu de cela il ya quinze jours ici
on parlait de la sphère castaner dont
tout le monde se fout de passants
parlent franchement castaner c'est une
scène la nouvelle idole des jeunes est
ce qui va rester pour rester
franchement français moyen qui cherche
un boulot et je peux le faire
deuxièmement aujourd'hui cette affaire
là thierry solère c'est quand même des
stars de la combinaison jemaye le désert
c'est ce qui me laisse que je trouve
ironique et sympathique dans cette
histoire c'est que hbo les constructif
qui sans doute attendait beaucoup sont
quand même les grands cocu les grands
cocus de l'histoire tirée l'ex leurs
pertes ou donc sur le plan de la morale
c'est assez intéressant après je pense
en même temps qu'il ya une forme de
cohérence idéologique au fait qu'il soit
chez en marche et peut-être que d'autres
à droite devrait faire pareil elle
parcourt camp républicain
dans le strip tease ma oui mais si vous
voyez ce que fait en marche
lui il était de centre-droit je trouve
que c'est assez logique
ce qui était illogique c'est qu'ils
continuent à dire alors voilà peut-être
pas lui qui continue à se scandaliser on
va me virer de l air lr cda d'affreux
fachos il me vire vire pas eu l air est
dans l'opposition et dans la majorité
c'est normal vous vous êtes dans ce
milieu là dedans vous comprenez que
c'est mais mettez-vous à la place d'un
français moi j'ai pensé genre hâtif
dans mon esprit il s'en fiche et
deuxièmement ça le scandalise quelqu'un
qui change d'avis comme de chemise comme
dit l'exposé mais il n'a pas changé
d'avis il a patiemment presqu'inchangé
loire témoins des républicains voilà
j'avais le moral c'est qu'il se fasse
élire clairoix des républicains alors
qu'elles savaient qu'ils allaient c'est
qu'il allait être un vide s'accrocher en
revanche il est manière dont il a un peu
dit mais c'est effectivement il ya aussi
la sphère du soffin le site du saut
transition merveilleuse de l'art de
manier modifiée de sorte qu'ils doivent
vient de rejoindre le gouvernement
socialiste est il
on va regarder il était à l'assemblée et
au sénat hier pour le budget budget
qu'il avait refusé d'ôter il ne l'est
pas si longtemps on regarde trop la vie
du soft est la réponse de david
assouline
permettez moi monsieur le président
quelques mots avant de donner l'avis du
gouvernement sur les amendements pour
vous dire l'honneur qui le mien de
pouvoir m'exprimer devant votre
assemblée
je sais d'expérience par l'expérience
que j'ai eue à l'assemblée nationale que
les compromis sont souvent possible ce
n'est pas banal
je pense même quasi unique que l'on
puisse voter contre un budget à
l'assemblée venir au nom du gouvernement
six jours après seulement
dire que l'on est pour et surtout le
défend avec quelques rires sur ce
plateau c'est ça ma faim il devrait
faire des courses à auteuil
deux chaises c'est vraiment
extraordinaire c'est fascinant comment
voulez-vous je reviens moi au public à
nous on regarde ça en sony mais quoi les
piscines notre finances en plus un
budget qui est clivant en plus ça le
pire c'est qu'il ya quand même deux dans
la réforme et c'est via la porte de lier
ses voeux la création d'un flat tax la
position base ou ne savent tout ça c'est
de rechercher olivier dussopt peut-être
pas le plus connu et moi tout
l'indispensable on voit tout de suite
que pour les hommes enfin on rigole on
se dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans
sa tête on comprend qu'il veut être
ministre et qu'il y fait tous les
compromis c'est assez pitoyable monté
derrière et c'est assez pour emmanuel
macron j'ai du mal à comprendre c'est
parce que s'ils l'envoient le lendemain
au sénat s'est créé au casse-pipe l'un
et il pense qu'on va dire là c'est
bienvenu macro élargi quelle grandeur
d'âme n'ont cessé alors ça c'est un
accroc encore une fois c'est ce qui est
pire dans la vieille politique là lavier
politique faisait pas ça comme ben je
crois que c'est le cépage nouveau monde
c'est le nouveau monde politiciens et
d'ailleurs c'est je pense le look grande
erreur dans l'analyse de l'élection de
d'emmanuel macron tout le monde a pensé
que c'était le renouveau et la fin des
syndicats des élus et en vérité c'est lé
syndicat d'élus qui se regroupent une
dernière fois pour survivre pour assurer
la survie dans un système qui va quand
même très très mal et on a vu le front
national au second tour de la
présidentielle quand même plein de
nouveaux intéressant qui était pas fait
pour être député qui se retrouvent
député ya aussi pas mal d'accord il
parlement là quelles nouvelles craintes
non mais il ya des meilleurs on reste
sur les mêmes sur les mêmes codes et
globalement sur le même logiciel
idéologique
parce qu'en réalité il y avait plus très
grande différence entre les sociaux
libéraux de droite et les libéraux se
fait cinq ans
oui c'est ça effectivement et ça
permettra peut être d'avoir une réelle
opposition en face mais en fait on est
dans la continuité des gouvernements
précédents s'excuser au nom de cette
nouvelle génération est encore plus
éloigné de nous le grand public que
n'était leurs prédécesseurs il suffit
alors si ce genre la proposition
sociologique de l'assemblée nationale
qui a jamais été jamais eu autant aussi
peu de classes populaires à l'assemblée
nationale que sous emmanuel macron donc
fait un peu de diversité on fait un peu
de féminité mais il n'y a pas de grandes
de deux ans vient du privé avant il y
avait beaucoup beaucoup de
fonctionnaires lassés des gens beaucoup
du privé après c'est vrai que c'est des
gens se sont logiquement oui une
profession libérale cadre du prix y est
prise et c'est à dire les remous dans
les rangs sont des gens alors qu'on te
dit ça il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
professions libérales mais qu'ils disent
qu'ils viennent d'un milieu populaire
c'est vrai qu'ils ont pris l'ascenseur
social
et alors ils sont étiquetés voilà mais
bon c'est vrai aussi c'est assemblée son
avocat soit que c'est pas le dire il
faut remonter à caen pour trouver bah je
sais pas même si la révolution la
convention c'est les méthodes et des
avocats s'étaient la bourgeoisie même
robespierre n'était pas vraiment été
envoyée fraser non après les syndicats
permettez ça quand ils étaient puissants
les symboles d'hier père médecin vous
permettez le permettez syndicale
elle permet t il y avait une formation
d'ailleurs une formation politique avant
il était d'une certaine façon il faisait
partie aussi d'une élite une certaine
élite qu'elles sont jusqu'à 70 75 y
avait une cohérence entre tous ces
hommes c'est que pour être conseiller
municipal ministre député il fallait
avoir été résistant donc il y avait dans
toutes les assemblées on pouvait se
saluer krasucki serrer la main de
chaban-delmas même s'ils n'étaient pas
d'accord et je dirais même que pour nous
électeurs le fait d'avoir en face de
nous des gens qui avaient fait un moment
de leur vie
preuve de courage physique on est une
facilité c'était une facilité parce que
même si on n'était pas d'accord on
disait quand même alors qu'aujourd'hui
les gens qui vous disent sur le pont
d'arcole je vais passer devant
attendons voir je vais attendre une au
moins nous par rapport à nos parents nos
parents ont eu des choix de vie ou de
mort des choix nous notre époque est peu
évident pour nous on a voté oui ou non à
maastricht on s'en souvient même plus on
n'a jamais risquer notre vie bon c'est
la paix aussi des castanéens c'est la
paix à ceux qui ont voté du simple alors
que honda mais d'ici neuf que
franchement c'était pas de nabeul on
s'en fiche complètement
mais ce qu'ils vont en profiter quand
même comme ça reviendra ou pas ce
sparadrap castaner double casquette ou
ça y est personne ne le connaît mais
c'est quand même tellement parce que les
gens s'en fichent un peu en fait
macron et moi ça fait presque partie des
côtés positifs que je lui reconnais une
pratique très bonne partie du tour il
avait annoncé l'horizontalité le nouveau
monde la démocratie participative
en fait il est très vème république et
il comprend d'ailleurs bien mieux la
vème république que nous elle ne la
comprenait françois hollande qui était
un peu un président de de la quatrième
après ce qui est étonnant c'est que
cette verticalité
à mon sens est au service d'une
politique du vide
ça peut paraître radicales à ma position
mais en tout cas d'une politique
extrêmement conformisme et qui nous
change pas beaucoup de ce qui a été fait
ces 30 dernières années et les premiers
pas de benjamin griveaux même si c'est
peut-être un peu anecdotique et daniel
bilalian va nous dire que les français
s'en fiche mais le nouveau propres
paroles ou non non je
moyens parce que je m'en fiche
franchement les premiers pas d'un
porte-parole un porte-parole saporta
parole donc le lui a dit qu'il allait
aller en province porter la bombe ou
prendre le pouls du pays c'est
extraordinaire parce que on reproche à
tort et je pense que vous vous lui
reprochez pas à mon avis à tort à
emmanuel macron doit être le président
des villes le président des bobos le
président de la france qui va bien et
pas le président enracinée qui n'a pas
d'âme comme divo qui trouve ça
absolument ridicule à mon avis il est
d'abord il vient d'amiens il est autant
de province que beaucoup d'hommes
politiques en bref chaque fois si
complexe et si il y en a bien moi j'ai
travaillé sur ce credo que tient pas
seulement à grimaud qui lui est le
parisien de la bande son porte parole et
nous disent vous savez je vais aussi
aller en pension il a été élu en
compétition où ça et il eut à oui mon
travail d'élu à paris oui et il a quand
même retrouvé un ancrage oui mais les
parisiens il ya un but parisien pour
dénoncer quoi il fallait avoir du bon
pour lui ça prouve qu'il n'y a pas tout
à fait temps et je dirais qu on lui
reproche pas de devenir de la ville ou
de la campagne
les reproches de de mener une politique
qui est dans l'intérêt des catégories
supérieures il est des grandes villes à
ce qu'il veut faire et je pense qu'elle
est un pays doit réconcilier en fait les
caisses comment qu'est ce qui ne fait
pas pour les petits il ya eu le congrès
des maires il ya quelques jours on peut
pas dire qu'ils étaient très heureux de
la politique des manuels mais il y avait
comme un plan de rénovation des
centre-villes et puis après les maires
écrit m'enfin c'est au tour décidé
l'ouverture des centres commerciaux en
périphérie des villes
irresponsabilité victime victimisation
responsabilités on est quoi beaufort sur
berra mais vous avez vu on a navigué
parce que je pense pas qu'ils vont chose
à dire on a quelques commentaires et
avant ça fait effectivement réagir ces
sujets trie on à guillaume de nantes qui
nous dit triste de voir ce retournement
de veste je sais pas si par louis parle
du solaire du sauf peut-être marie
bertinet dans cinq ans on remet ça
génial l'europe alors ça c'est autre
chose et puis geppetto qu'elle
dégradation de l'image de notre présence
de nos représentants l'abstention va
être de rigueur
mais c'est sûr ces les électeurs ça
quand même dans la sphère du soap et
c'est ridicule et même envoyer ce fait
il le portait sur son visage vous ne
veut pas faire de mai mais quand même
globalement on a quand même rénové de la
france insoumise ou front national même
en passant par l air et de l parti
socialiste grâce au non cumul des
mandats il ya un renouvellement du
personnel politique énorme le
gouvernement je suis pas sûr que daniel
bilalian puisse nommer plus de trois ou
quatre ministres moi je veux nommer six
ou sept voiliers ayant causé la mort le
sport quand même mauvais mais c'est la
mort des poids lourds politiques il y en
a qui vont devenir tous alors on est je
suis patient je pense que ma macron
affaire a volontairement au gouvernement
plutôt de techno ou de second couteau
pour avoir la main et finalement moi je
lui reproche pas l'âge dans la technique
du pouvoir je pense qu'il a raison parce
qu'il ya beaucoup moins de quoi est ce
que j'ai en 1 20 à l'époque de 120 dans
trois ans est ce qu'aujourd'hui dans le
contexte qui est le nôtre d'une paix
en france depuis soixante dix ans et on
peut encore et avec le temps qui
s'écoule avant par exemple de lire un
homme comme monsieur mitterrand il a
échoué deux fois aux élections
présidentielles avant d'être élu est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui ce serait possible non
donc formé regardez laurent wauquiez
doit être le président du lr en six mois
alors que chirac ami x dizaine d'années
si je crois que le temps aujourd'hui qui
est celui d'une autre le temps internet
ne permettra plus de voir émerger des
personnalités de ce type là enfin il
faut à présent 50 ans nous dirons que on
a élu président de macron parce qu'il
est à la mode et que dans cinq ans un
autre sera à la mode comme les
téléphones via un choix clair de nous
quand les rencontres de s'entourer de
gens on profite plutôt technicien je
n'aime pas trop ça mais oui de gens
professionnels c'est pas c'est pas dégeu
c'est pas des gens qui ont fait de la
politique
après ces gens qui y vont quand on
discute avec les partenaires sociaux
patronat les syndicats médicaux ils
apprécient parce qu'enfin quelqu'un au
ministère du travail et quand même alors
qu'à 10% de chômeurs quelqu'un qui
connaît la relation sociale
ça aide les grands comme les chiens
navires n'ont pas eu besoin d'être
forcément des grands spécialistes pour
faire des droits oui sur la wii
certes gasquet piège thomas legrand
qu'elle est l'intitulé de la fonction
des oliviers du soft que vous
affectionnez particulièrement bas je
crois qu'il est secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre des comptes publics mais
secrétaire d'état à chennai et de la
faune que la fonction publique donc en
plus de la fonction publique donc le
jour de carence par exemple j'imagine
qu'il est et ça ça va être bien on va se
régaler avec lui ça va est je porte la
page 2 du canard
merci beaucoup les quatre c'était très
animée et ne quittait pas figaro lights
figaro live
restez avec nous marie laëtitia bonavita
reçoit le sociologue julien d'amont
julien d'en manquer l'auteur de un monde
de bidonvilles et qui estime que l'état
est totalement dépassé par la question
de l'accueil des migrants et que ce
dossier doit revenir aux métropoles
c'est tout de suite sur figaro live et à
demain pour un nouveau point de vue
[Musique]